how to defeat the swamps efforts to take
down
Trump's nominees that's the focus of
tonight's angle it has been 15 months
since the Trump inauguration and yet
there's still more than 500 positions
across the federal government that have
yet to be filled by Trump appointees
these range from Assistant Secretary of
State for political military affairs to
Assistant Secretary of Homeland Security
for Policy now from my own experience in
both the Education Department the
Transportation Department and also at
the White House it's at that assistant
secretary or maybe associate deputy
level that's where all the work gets
done
well the fault lies partly in the
administration itself think about this
the office of presidential personnel
it's really important it runs the
president's staffing is now overburdened
and understaffed Obama's office of
presidential personnel had three times
the staff of what Trump has now it takes
people actual employees in that office
to process names Shepard the vetting
process and do real follow-through on
people who are suggested to various
positions now I realize that Trump wants
to cut the size of government but there
are better places to cut then OPP and of
course most responsible for this
travesty though of all these delays and
all the foot-dragging
are the Democrats stopping Trump from
putting his own people in key positions
what does it do what's obvious it slows
down
Trump's progress 431 of president
Trump's nominees have received Senate
confirmation that's a far lower number
than any other president at this point
in their terms now Democrats have
continuously invoked a rule that
requires 30 hours of debate on many of
trumps appointees so that means that
nominees wait an average of 84 days for
confirmation that's a lot longer also
than previous administrations more than
50% of Trump's nominees for federal
judgeships are still awaiting
confirmation
Democrats obstruction efforts are having
a negative impact on the basic functions
of our government it causes in
efficiencies and it even can put our
national security at risk the Senate has
yet to act on the nominations of several
key diplomatic posts most notably with
Richard Grinnell the harvard-educated
diplomat is president Trump's nominee to
be ambassador for Germany and he's being
held up by one Democrat Senator Jim
Merck jeff merkley excuse me of oregon
now what could mix McConnell do to move
things along as the Senate Majority
Leader well he could tell Chuck Schumer
at the following hey Chuck the Senate's
not gonna recess until you all start
dispensing with this 30 hour rule and
start allowing votes on key nominees
these guys want to get home on the
weekends you don't think to start
picking up the pace and if he needs to
change or dispense with the filibuster
rule he may need to do that too you
can't let this continue remember in 2013
then Senate Majority Leader Harry Reid
blew up the filibuster rule for federal
appointments in the executive branch
like cabinet officials and the judicial
branch and this is how Obama was able to
pack the lower courts as he did well
Trump can do the same here Donald
Trump's frankly been asking for that but
now some are looking to put another
scalp on the wall and I'm talking to
Democrats who do they want Mike Pompeo
scalp Trump's CIA director who has been
nominated for Secretary of State
now during his confirmation hearing
America saw the Democrats demonization
game on full display auditioning for
20/20 was New Jersey's cory booker is
being gay a perversion senator I when I
was a politician I had a very clear view
on whether it was appropriate for two
same-sex persons to marry I stand by
that and you believe that gay sex is a
perversion yes or no Senate if I if I
can if yes or no if you believe in gay
sex is a perversion now Democrats claim
to be again
discrimination except when they're
discriminating so if you're someone who
holds a traditional out look like any
faithful Catholic for instance other
Christians should we now assume that you
need not apply to any of these positions
then there were swings and misses
like this one from senator jeanne
Shaheen you were criticized at the CIA
for undermining policies of the previous
administration administration to improve
diversity at the CIA I don't know the
criticism that you're referring to I
have to tell you I didn't undermine a
single policy well I would just say
Michael Weinstein who is a former Air
Force officer who founded the military
Religious Freedom Foundation says that
he has been seeing increasing complaints
from those inside the intelligence
community under your leadership the
number of we call them no fear
complaints the statutory requirement
decreased from 2016 to 2017 by 40% good
I like the good that's just pathetic
come on all right
even Dianne Feinstein who's usually more
reasonable in these matters and voted to
confirm Pompeo as CIA director just last
year
she's announced that she's voting
against him because he's too hawkish at
a time when we need more diplomacy okay
he only traveled in North Korea over
Easter weekend met with Kim jong-un and
laid the groundwork for president
Trump's upcoming negotiations with the
communist regime that's all I mean that
is truly historic and it could it could
be a monumental move for peace don't
worry about that die fine but the
Democrats let's face it they don't care
to let the facts get in the way if the
choice is supporting the anti-trump
resistance or supporting policies that
deliver real results the Democrats are
going to choose the resistance every
time it is despicable now consider some
of the supposed reasons that some
senators are now opposing Pompeo he has
devalued religious tolerance and women's
reproductive rights and health care and
not only in this country but around the
world I think he sets a poor example in
terms of American values American values
like I don't know what you consider to
be American sir but Mike Pompeo is life
is a shining example of what sacrifice
for nation is all about first his class
at West Point Harvard law top of his
class popular congressman stellar CIA
director for the last year who won the
respect and trust of the President of
the United States 39 in the Democratic
caucus are expected to vote no already
on Pompeo and nine are undecided this is
the time to test the so-called moderate
Senate dynamic Democrats from states
that Trump won smartly Heidi Heitkamp of
North Dakota just came out today as the
first Democrat to support Pompey's
nomination but no word yet on senators
Joe Donnelly of Indiana Joe Manchin of
West Virginia and Claire McCaskill of
Missouri when those guys are out
campaigning for re-election as they are
now
they're always cup claiming that oh I'm
open to working with the President on
issues where you know it's important for
the American public well let me let me
talk to them here Pompey owes nomination
is a key issue for America and those
senators know as well as I do that he's
more than a reasonable choice for
Secretary of State he is an excellent
choice and each of these senators should
be called out and pressured to break
with their leftist radical colleagues
for the good of the nation and if they
don't vote for Pompeo they are no more
moderate than Cory Booker or Elizabeth
Warren